I like knowing that I can be there for
people without actually being and that's
a nice feeling I've always been a very
honest open writer I've always been on
my heart and my sleeve my horses my is
my instrument so sometimes I sing things
that just sound crazy but then like one
tank out of 20 will be really really
cool hello bleep nation its Ivan my one
word is believe and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves and
my sincere hope is that if you see in
yourself what I see in you you'll be
able to change the planet so to help you
on your journey today we're gonna learn
from Grammy award-winning singer and
songwriter Ellie Goulding and my take on
our top 10 rules for success rule number
one is our personal favorite and I'd
love to know which one you guys like the
best also as you're watching if you hear
something that really resonates with you
please leave it down in the comments
below I put quotes around it so other
people can be inspired by it as well and
if you leave it within the first couple
hours of this video going live you have
a chance to win one of two daily prizes
often fans tell me that the music I make
has helped them through things with
their family and their friends and
boyfriend and girlfriend help them you
know reconcile with a father or mother
or whoever that's quite a nice feeling
that my music can do that this is
devotion I like knowing that I can be
there for people without actually being
that's a nice feeling I try to be there
for my own family that they're my fans
it's nice I can produce something that
is you know comforting
Josie
[Applause]
[Music]
oh sure
my writing style has always been very
hopeful I don't like writing
depressing songs unless I can offer some
kind of resolution and that's also how
I've always written even when I wrote
lease to write poetry and essays and
[ __ ] when I was young I write my songs
in a very specific way like even if
they're about someone it will never be
like oh that's about that you know like
it would never be it's never like shade
or burn or any of that kind of stuff I
don't believe in that I believe in you
know I write I write songs I like to
write songs at the resolution I like to
write songs always with something
positive so even if I write about
somebody that's broken my heart or
somebody that's hurt me or a situation
I've been in it's been unpleasant I
still want to try and write like a poet
you know I still want to buy something
that is timeless like Shakespeare
I want to write things that you really
you know stand stand true forever I see
the good in everyone and I see the good
in everything and I think that there's
always a silver lining and there's
always a there's always good to come out
of everything
and so if you know it's my lyrics
there's always a resolution of some kind
as always like think everything's going
to be okay moment yeah um so even if I
see yeah even if I have been in
situations where I think that was really
unfair that was mean or that was you
know I was hurt by something I was
trying to do it in a way that resolved
it in my own head I think like I think
as a writer I progressed in that like
I've always been a very honest open
writer I've always been on my heart on
my sleeve the way that I write lyrics
and tell stories without sound like a
cliche be very honest
my situation about my childhood about my
boss
it kind of contributes to my right and
who I do as an artist so I think it's
important to shed light on my wife you
know
and I never I always feel weird if I
leave some ow
not knowing something about me
I did listen to a bit of Joni Mitchell
to listen to I have listened to a lot of
Feist and my brightest Island and
another Michael Rilo Kiley's I really
like their lyrics and it was suddenly I
realized that you could be quirky but
you could also still be quite poppy in
it my mum can't listen to pop and dance
music so it was very pop and I wasn't in
shoes to any old bands the more I was
discovering music by myself so it was
kind of a discover it was me discovering
things that would allow me to find out
about older bands and older singers
maybe it could be that I have a very
kind of unique a sort of way in that
I've listened to a hell of a lot of
quite obscure folk music and and yuck
and then but then I also really loved
pop music and but I refuse to let one of
them overtake the other so I think
that's why I seem to have been given
this this appreciation in blocks and in
a lot of in you know like enemy and not
sort of a more of an indie area and then
and then also I seem to have this sort
of pop thing as well I guess my lyrics
are just really important to me I never
wanted me to be too alien and
complicated but I never you know I want
me to have a meaning always so it's like
it's always a finding the right kind of
balance and my and my songs of surreal
it's surreal staff and then very real
stuff that's very Universal and
relatable so for me it's always finding
that balance within my tracks yeah I
write things on my laptop a lot and now
that I've got a laptop I write on my
phone I write on paper
it depends sometimes I kind of have to
be in a certain frame of mind to write I
could I have to be sometimes I have to
be quite down sometimes has to be really
related but generally it's me coming up
with some chords and some words and
something I really want to write about
something I need to get off my chest
what do you think that this panel is
seeing in you that they have decided
that you hit it
I don't know and I wish I did because it
would be a lot easier
I suppose I'm quite normal and I wasn't
necessarily ambitious so I guess I don't
really have a business kind of mind so
in that way up my music ends up being I
hate using this phone but quite organic
in that I write things you know I just
go at it blind and just hope for the
best and that's happened that's how I've
always worked I sort of like to do
things at them in the moment so if I
have a resolution that I want to make I
just kind of do it actually you know I
want to be a bit more adventurous next
year as in I want to like be a bit more
of a like adventure seeker do some sky
dives and stuff but like don't think I
can do a bungee jump I think that's a
bit too far you could skydive but you
couldn't bungee jump I think it's very
different bungee don't you throw
yourself off at least skydive skis right
coming in that fat and just takes you
with them yeah I think minded it was a
whole different thing but yeah I think I
want to do things that kind of scare me
and get over my fears a bit more next
year so maybe I maybe I do have some new
resolutions actually I mean supporting
Bruno Mars and I supported quite a few
artists in arenas so I feel like I've
been lucky in that respect because I've
built a stamina that's required of
playing such big shows but they haven't
been my show so the pressures been off
so I've been able to practice playing to
lots of people but like I said the
pressure is is off in that it's not my
own show and I can sort of I don't know
it's it's definitely easier supporting
someone in an arena like the crowd is
not necessarily there to support you but
you can win them over and it kind of
makes you realize that you have to put
on a really special show to get people's
favor so I've been able to do that and
then my own shows I go back and do my
own shows and I sort of replicate what I
do in arenas and it makes the show a bit
bigger and a bit more special what is it
like as a writer as a musician at a time
when there is this glut I mean once upon
a time and again show me as I apologize
for this but I can't help it something
like you would have come along and in a
way there would have been one of it
maybe - where's now and not to say that
that
they're exactly the same but you know
what I'm saying that there can be a lot
of the same kind of thing appears so I
wondered how difficult it is for you to
try and generate the kind of originality
that you really want to have well I
think the important thing is is not is
not to try and hopefully you don't have
to try and luckily I feel like I've been
given that that kind of advantage in
that I feel like I'm not trying hard to
create something that's original but
because I have such a passion for the
folk music and music which is which is
so simple and beautiful with just a
guitar and it just so happens that I've
I've constructed my songs that way
without thinking about it too much and
not putting to much kind of you know God
this song has you know has to be
different it has to be but it also has
to be mainstream to that I sell records
it's completely not like that it's just
the fact that myself and my producer
star Smith it's the same age and he has
a passion for electronic music I have a
passion for folk music in particular but
you also have to listen to a lot of the
same things when were younger so we just
we just go into a session and we slowly
start to construct a song and I usually
already have the kind of the backbone
for it but I think yeah I mean it's easy
enough for me to say this what I think
the best thing is not is not to try
heart because you can you can almost
tell and I think that's where the
breaker of connection between you and
and your your listeners that so the
break comes because they can't connect
because they can either notice almost
sense that it's like a to try hard or
whatever that's key to everything that's
key to what I do I wouldn't be here
without experimenting like crazy I I
like to I didn't types of music and I
hope that I could get away with
including all of those different
influences on my first record I think I
got away with it and maybe my second as
well but I mean like I would say that
I'm a pop artists I'm a pop music but
it's not without a lot of
experimentation and also you know
risking doing you know writing something
that maybe isn't very good or is or is
silly you know my voice is my it is my
instrument so sometimes I sing things
just sound crazy but then like one take
out of 20 will be really really cool and
then I keep that one then that's that
so yeah it's fermentation is everything
for me as a musician yeah when I tweet
it today that you were going to do
another interview we got all kinds of
questions one of them was how do you
feel about so many people remix it sorry
I well a lot of real room it's that and
a lot of people remix once I've just
kind of blown up out of nowhere and it's
amazing I love hearing my song with a
completely different feel to it I love
the idea that my vocal can just be put
onto pretty much anything lights has
been remixed by every single artist
right now in the planet it seems like
you have a favorite version Bassnectar
remix has always been my favorite he's
not my big one I Lauren so it's so funny
how it remix started off our friendship
but yeah also like it really
kick-started lights in the States
because like at first when when lights
started getting like having some kind of
prominence in America it was always like
oh yeah I love the Bassnectar remix at
first and then all of a sudden like
lights was creeping up and it had its
own journey so yeah but there's there's
there's probably about a thousand lights
remixes out there I'm not joking it's
miss remix song probably of all time
I've been probably most remix artist in
the UK so some remixes I'm just like
okay that's that's okay but then someone
listened to you I think that's better
than the original and I've really fallen
up with them like a couple months - Adi
from France remixed guns and horses and
just blew me away or I thought God it
sounded like it was supposed to be like
at the end of the film like something
epic like a love story because it was
amazing it made me cry a little bit so I
just put my sight it was all suck it
wasn't my song anymore it's just sent
this amazing thing that's on a creative
I really like her I've read a lot since
I was young so books inspire me at
Murakami's for some folks poetry I've
read a lot of poetry in the last few
years and I like kind of dark like the
funny kind of humorous stuff like I've I
read too I read a big book of poems
staying alive a compilation of poems yes
I really like real and roar and and and
quite express it and so I use those and
then obviously like other singers other
bands musicians and classical music and
I listen to so much stuff that I'm just
kind of inundated all the time so that's
kind of how I work really listened to a
lot of music all the time now it's just
Internet is used by so many people and
that you know this so much downloading
that it's just it's it's become the way
and more people are getting iPods more
people finding their music and so it's
kind of they're more attracted to
internet stuff but but the yeah the I
guess there's there's more there's more
ways of finding out music meaning and
get things like track in a box you get
get a track sent to you every day and
you find out things that way and maybe
me personally I do feel like there's so
much music that that it's impossible for
me as a maker of new music to be
completely aware of everything I just go
on random recommendations and people
give me and I might discover something
for myself
I think that's the best way because you
can get just inundated with just you
just get so much stuff thrown at you
I can beatbox oh yeah we'll forget that
a little bit oh that's good I don't know
good try
all right eyebrows a little one no it's
getting up yeah
and then you like in one
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because SH island
Reinstein asked me to if there's someone
you like me to profile in their future
top ten please check out the link down
in the description below and you can
cast your vote on who we should do next
I also want to give a quick shout out to
Marta Magdalena Marta thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book your
one word and posting that awesome
message on Twitter I'm so glad that
you're coming back to it and rereading
it whenever you're having moments of
doubt I really appreciate that and for
sharing it as well thank you thank you
thank you so much and I'm really happy
you enjoyed the book thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope we continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon
[Music]
how's all your new stuff going so
obviously your sounds evolved a lot
since the first album how's it being
taken ah it's pretty good like the
second album has gotten me around the
world and got me
to get some ghosts some cool places it's
definitely like I think everything's
evolved like I've I've managed to sort
of get worldwide a bit more and tour
places I'd never talked before and it's
all evolved in general like touring and
the record and just everything yeah I
don't know really I feel like I do I do
work really hard but I sort of stay at a
level that I'm really comfortable and
happy with I genuinely never wanted to
be a superstar
I just just didn't it just never really
occurred to me that that would ever be
possible I'm grateful for every day
because I get this foot Bruno freakin
Mars on tour like I just don't
understand it so long as I have that
which I do every day I just I have the
best time I get to write songs and put
them on a record and some people buy
limbs and then down and it's I've yeah a
really fun time with it the biggest
thing I probably go to if I'm kind of an
if I'm kind of in a rush is a hype
machine I've gone hype machine a lot I
go on air milk blog quite a lot but you
know I I feel like I'm very lucky
because I've been connected with so many
producers and DJs just from like remixes
and from working with people and having
an affinity with electronic music the I
I get to meet people and people send me
stuff and have connections with a lot of
people so um yeah I guess just cuz I've
been doing it for such a long time like
the first people that I reached out to
on myspace for the electronic producers
baryon Frank music and a bunch of people
Roscoe
so like I've you know I've been I think
I think that people appreciate that I
have that connection with electronic
music and just well it just my love of
so many different types of music has
kind of led me to that